how excited is it to be nominated
tonight and what would it mean to win oh
my God it's the most
most of my life I feel
you have built such a unique following
around the world and what does that mean
to watch people fall in love with you
and your music and your performances
globally
uh ego exercise because in my country
I'm like the biggest artist and
everything and then here I'm starting
from the zero again and you got to put
yourself back to the point that you were
when you started your career and for me
it's amazing I love doing that because
it's like experience the whole things
I've been through but again in another
territory and like it's just amazing I
love that I love new challenges new
experiences do you also think that the
documentary really helped introduce you
to so many people I think it does help a
lot even more like my culture because
it's very different like Brazilian
people we are a Latin country but we
speak Portuguese we don't speak Spanish
so it's not the same thing when I say
that I think also because you're off the
chain I mean you are you you give it to
us don't
I'm a little I'm a little I loved it
it's a little craziness a little
business a little everything a little a
little bit of everything what would it
mean to win I think it would be history
to my country right now my country is
waiting for this night as a World Cup
game and I don't know I'm just I just
hope I win because the frustration is
going to be crazy they will be looking
they're looking all of Brazil is
watching tonight they are I swear
everyone tell me about the dress real
quick it's Natalia Versace 2003 spring
summer uh vintage piece and I'm feeling
unique as this piece you are unique
though you're a unique artist you're
unique art you are a piece
I'll trade
my legs are like
going crazy bro so it's heavy I'm good
at where I went to the gym this whole
week because now I'm like prepared good
luck tonight good luck tonight we're
rooting for you thank you take care
[Music]
foreign